[Music]
thank you very much
i will have to start by apologizing
because
you all came to a conference called
jsconf
oh it's not
plugged in yes
will it come in there
let's
see oh yeah there it is so you all came
to a conference called jsconfirm this is
a second talk and i will not be talking
about javascript at all
so sorry for that but thanks for having
me anyway
i will uh instead be talking about uh
history of art uh web design and css
development yeah best programming
language of all of them
and i
i want to talk about um art first and i
want to introduce you to two artists
that i like very much the first one is
jackson pollock he lived from 1912 to
and
he always liked to stage himself as if
he was an actor because apparently it
was hard
in the 40s and 50s to be an artist and
still keep your masculinity so he was
always
photographed like this so with a
cigarette in his mouth and he was
drinking a lot of alcohol and in the end
he died while driving his car into a
tree while drunk so it's very actor-like
um but let's not talk about his life
let's talk about his art um his art
looks like this
this one is called autumn rhythm number
30. i have to read this
and it's quite huge it's more than five
meters and uh
2.5 meters in the height so
nearly like this
and uh the way he was painting was um
not in the traditional way but he was
having the canvas on the floor and then
he was walking around and
throwing some paint on it sometimes uses
brushes but also sticks or pouring the
paint directly onto
the canvas
from the cam
by the way the time is now running so
maybe could someone start this so i will
keep on talking forever
so um and he uh was
always
there are interviews and he was saying
that he was picking up vibes from the
landscape and translating this into a
piece of art
so uh taking something that is invisible
uh feelings and so on and there's also
interviews where he's saying though
he's painting and then all of a sudden
he says now i lost the connection to the
painting so there's a lot of emotion
going on and he needs a connection to
this
um
here's another one
and this one's called blue poles
uh what's interesting about this one is
uh it's the first painting that was
sold for more than two million uh
dollars not the first painting ever but
the first modern art painting
and it was uh so to uh the australian
national gallery
and the people in australia they were
really
angry about this because all of their
money uh that they paid in texas was uh
used to buy this um
but
it's worth much more nowadays um so yeah
that's all this so um and here finally
you can see him painting so you see the
canvas on the floor and him going around
and splashing the paint almost and
i want you to remember to keep in mind
that there's a lot of emotion
that he needs to connect to and that he
wants to
uh fix on the canvas so let's the first
artist here
second one
uh we travel back in time a little bit
uh is filippo bonoleski uh he lived in
the
from 1377 to 1446
and he is mostly known for building the
dome in florence if you've ever been to
florence uh he is the architect and he's
very proud of this you can see this he's
holding a picture up there
um
but what i really like about
brunelleschi is that he is the one who
invented the central linear perspective
so he's the one who
taught us that if you want to translate
some
three-dimensional object onto a
two-dimensional surface
it mustn't look like this
but it should look much more like this
or
maybe like this depending on your taste
of 90s video games
um
so and because this was new and it was
nobody did that before uh he had to
convince other people that this is the
way of doing this
so um because everything that is new
people first don't trust this
so in made an experiment to convince
people that his technique is right
and he did this by
painting a little panel of the baptistry
that is also in florence
and
he was able to obviously you can see
it's an octagonal building and he was
able to mathematically calculate the
scale of all the objects around there
and paint this
on a little panel so he had this
and
then to to tell people okay this is the
correct way of
painting a central perspective
thing
um
he positioned himself in the front of uh
the dome down there
um and
he made you look onto the baptistry
that's in front of the dome
and then okay this gets a little bit
difficult
you had to hold up this panel in front
of you but
looking away from you so you looked at
the backside and there's a little
peephole and you look through it onto
the baptistry and then he held up a
mirror
so that you could see
this
it looks like this so
here you can see that as soon as you
have the mirror up you see the painting
and if you take this away you see the
real thing and this is how he convinced
people that this is the right way of
painting
and to make it even more complex you can
see up there the sky was also reflecting
so it was not painted so you can see you
could see the real moving clouds
on top of the constructed painting
[Music]
yes that's me drinking
sadly
this panel is lost we just know about
this from writing
but there's something else
here we have um brunelleschi and he had
a buddy called masaccio
and just goes by massachu like you know
madonna chair
and
bunleski himself he wasn't that much of
a painter he was an architect but
massage he was and um brunelleschi told
him about his findings on
uh painting and doing the perspective
stuff and with this knowledge
massachusetts was
able to paint the trinita this is
the godfather holding his son jesus and
the white thing up there that's a little
dove that's uh the holy christ holy
spirit sorry
and
uh you can see here that all the lines
are
going down to this little point down
there
uh and this is the first known painting
that uses the central linear perspective
and
the point is down there because
when you go to uh the church where you
can see this it's painted onto a wall
and the santa maria novella also in
florence
you can see that your eye level is down
there
um so this is you're standing in front
of this and this is where you're looking
and then you look up into
the contract constructed ceiling here
everything is really constructed here
and so please don't ask me why this
happened
i have no idea
so
yeah
so now you get to know the two artists
uh jackson and filippo
and let's make have them look at each
other
uh
he
does a lot of emotion and you can see uh
brunelleschi he is a lot of he's a
mathematic
lover so he does all this he's an
architect
and i could have used other artists here
as well
this one here is claude monet
edward monk
also very famous for translating
expressions on nature and so into
a piece of art but i could also have
used banksy uh he does graffiti stuff
and for banksy it is a lot of um
society politics but also something that
is invisible and he makes this
he puts this into a piece of art
on the other hand for mathematics of
course there's leonardo da vinci i guess
a lot of you have heard of him
m.c escher is another example but
there's also artists that are still
alive like uh coast for hoof
he takes computer generated fractals and
makes
sculptures out of this so this is all
the mathematical stuff and here we have
a lot of emotion
now
i want to make a little experiment
and i want to try
i'll
try to imagine what would it look like
if these two
were not artists back in their time but
were
living today and were web designers
so two web designers
um what would their work look like
and let's start with uh jackson over
here
and i think he would always talk like
doing a mood board and
collecting all stuff that is is needed
and then he would start maybe search for
a key visual
and try to find the perfect visual to
transport the message that he wants to
try
to show to the users and of course
the key visual is not perfect so he has
to adjust it and has to adjust some
lightning and the contrast and make
everything
just
to have the right mood
on the other hand bunleski will probably
give you a design system with buttons
and give you a
headings and typography
all of these margins and so on and of
course an accessible color palette
and what they're working on is maybe
let's see uh jackson here will be
working on on a landing page like this
like for this cappuccino whatever stuff
or
cupcakes i think it is
and uh on the other hand uh
bunaleski will probably work on some
dashboard application
[Applause]
so two very different types of designers
and now again these two designers get
the same simple task they get the task
of
give me a design uh with a headline and
two paragraphs and one of these
paragraphs there's a link in that
and let's start with bonoleski he says
okay i can do this a headline two
paragraphs and a link
looks like this
uh that's good and now there's a
developer coming in
here she is we will call her getty for
no special reason
and uh
here uh maybe uh monolith used
figma and she has a look at the headline
and uses the inspect tool and it looks
like this so she sees okay the text has
a name it's text for xl
you see the font weight and your font
style and the color also has a name it's
black
so he uses some some design tokens here
maybe
and and what she does to translate this
into html and css
she can
basically copy all of this and use some
um css classes over here so um for the
headline for the h2 she says okay text
forex l this is from a system you may
have
uh already guessed this is uh tailwind
classes here so it's a lot of utility
classes that she uses and abundantly
seems to know this as well so in order
to translate this into a website mostly
she can use the inspect tool copy stuff
that is shown there and copy this into
the code and doesn't have to write css
at all and it looks like this and uh
well she goes over there and says it's
perfect um
let's work together all the time
no
let's see what he does
he gets the same task give me a headline
two paragraphs and a little link in
there
and it says okay if if i just do this
and nothing more and i don't have i'm
not allowed to use images or whatever
um let's make it like this
and um
yes um here she comes again
looks at this and says okay there is no
name for the headline and uh okay the
font weight is okay but the font size is
159.
58.91 pixels
line height is 160.5 pixels and the
color i don't i'm not sure is that pure
black or
maybe not so
um she looked at this and i said okay
we need to talk
because you know what this looks awesome
and uh i want to do this and i now wanna
show you the process of what get here or
developer does to translate this layout
here into a proper website
now look at this again and let's see
what makes this layout special what
makes it
stand out and there's three things
first thing is the headline
the headline is so huge it's not about
readability here it's like it's a
substitute for an image because he
couldn't use an image he just had these
huge uh letters that are screaming at
you
second thing is the paragraphs they are
here it is about readability so length
of the um lines here is nice uh the line
height is nice so it's perfectly
readable
and the last thing is um the layout
itself you may already have seen that
it's not completely centered it's a
little bit to the right and of course
the paragraphs are on the right side of
the headline not on the left side so
this is what makes this layout special
and let's address these things one by
one
yeah thanks for that um first the
headline
um
you know it was these complex uh
things here but let's just round this up
to the size is 160 pixels and the lineup
is also 160 pixels
but instead of using pixels we can of
course use another unit and
because this always needs to be very
huge and we want to have very huge
letters we can use
viewport units
so this looks like this we have the font
size of 1 em plus 10 vw
that's for the viewport width and the
calculation here is for accessibility
reasons so
we make sure that the font size will
never be
smaller than 1 em
um so
let's uh just here
and this is all we need to have this
headline be always quite huge
depending on
the
width of the screen
next thing let's have a look at the
paragraph here um the important thing if
you can read this is
720 pixels for the width of the
paragraph
and
again yeah 720 pixels pixels are
in my opinion not the perfect unit to
use when working with a css and on
screen so instead of using 720 pixels as
a max width i can put in a bunch of
zeros down here
and y zeros because there is a
not that known uh css property called ch
and once the h is the width of the
character zero in the given font size
and font family and font weight
so if for some reason uh the browser
does not load this font the font firmly
and get you get another font it will
still be
this nearly the same size and then
same line length over here
so we can use
max width of 50 ch 50 characters so you
will have roughly 50 characters
as a max width for this paragraph
also very useful when you're doing a
block or whatever you have with a lot of
writing and you want to define a nice
reading length for your
line length for your typography
last thing is the layout itself you can
see there are
four columns
and three of them
on the right you have 114 pixels 344 and
230.
yeah okay this is pixels again let's try
to see something that is not pixels over
here
and we can say that if you multiply
these 114 by 2 you get roughly
230 and multiplying it by 3 you get
roughly 344
so it's one third two thirds and three
thirds
and what's also important here is that
most of these columns are mostly
occupied by just white space
and distributing white space
that is
something that can perfectly done by
using
css grid
and css grid is just perfect for that
and i will show you how this looks
um you have a wrapper class around this
uh let's say it's called fancy text
and you give it this display grid
and then you use grid template columns
2fr3fr auto1fr
the 2 is for the 2fr over here the three
of our there three two time parts three
parts auto for the text and one part
and the fr unit works like this you can
always remember like
whenever there's space to distribute put
two parts over here three parts over
here and one part over here so when
there's six pixels
two go here three go there and one goes
there but only if there is space to
distribute
um
and then we have to place
our
our text onto the grid so for the
headline we start with grid column two
four
two is because the first line would be
over here
and uh it started for ends at the fourth
line and uh the paragraph also goes to
i'll start at the third and ends over
there at the fourth
and
putting all of this together
you get this piece of css
it's 21 lines
uh there's a little bit more going on
you have the grid stuff uh up there in
line one two five there's a little bit
of margin in there
then you have the headline it gets of
course the line height and the font
weight and the good column
and for the paragraph
you can see i also add a little edit a
little bit of viewport width to the font
size here in line 16 but it's not that
much that we used for the headline
and uh the important stuff here of
course is the max width of 50 characters
and
this may not be the easiest piece of css
that you have seen
in your life but this is something that
gives you a totally responsive
design
that works without media queries and
will always
respect the designer's intention and
this is how it looks
so
you can see that
if you resize the browser
everything resizes really nicely and as
soon as there's enough space you can see
that the text gets indented and here's
another example
where you can see how the white space is
distributed
so it's always a little bit to the right
you have the two columns over here the
one part over there
and this will be 50 characters and and
and the three parts will be calculated
over here and i think this is kind of
really just magic
and
what is important here that
the designers artists intention is still
there so you see what makes this layout
special and in mostly all screen sizes
you can see this design
and
all of this
is only possible if you remember that at
this point here
she said
this is awesome and we can do this
instead she could have said well you
know what you don't understand the
medium
you don't know uh how this works but
don't worry
uh here's a figma template with tailwind
components and you know what
the developer experience is much better
if you just stick to these and use all
of this
and by developer experience it's of
course hurt
or read my experience
and if a designer hears this then
well maybe
they get
first angry and then sad
and
we don't want this to happen
so
before coming to an end i now want to
talk a little bit about all the
characters that we've seen today
and i want to add another developer over
here
she goes by the name get here as well
um
and while our first schedy is a lot of
does a lot of css and maybe a little
presentational javascript um
the other one is more into let's say
frameworks view
react you name it
and you all know that there is uh this
discussion uh this discourse going
around and i will name this the great
divide after the article by great by
chris coyer if you haven't read it do
um and and you know there's a lot of
stuff going on and do we need is the
front end developer now a full stack
developer do we need full stick
developers do we need to divide this
even more do we have a front of the
front end and the back of the front end
and
if you search for this on twitter you
find lots and lots of opinions about
this
on the other hand there's also a lot of
discussion going on on the design level
you could argue is there something like
a full stack designer is that a thing
but there's another question
uh that's even older than the other one
and that is the question of should
designers learn how to code
and all of this
um i think
it's a lot of these discussions are a
little bit unhealthy we need to do this
but
um
it's still a thing of people talking
about each other and designers talking
about developers and so on and i'd love
to have this
a little more
coming closer together and the people
that are doing design tools are doing a
great job of
doing this so nowadays you have in in
figma the auto layout that works like
flexbox so things are coming closer
together and what i really hope
is that things don't look like this but
instead look like this so that there's
an overlap and all of these people can
communicate with each other
and i really love to work in a team that
looks like this
and if you also want to have a team like
this
be careful how you write your job
descriptions and don't be too explicit
because it could be that someone is
maybe over here
and if you put up some barriers people
could say that okay i'm i'm not um
my skills are not sufficient enough
because there there's some
back-end technology in there that i
don't know but still there may be value
over here
or let's say you have a designer that is
here
and
they maybe
know a little bit of code maybe no
budget of js but are afraid of using the
terminal or are not confident using
github but still there's a lot of value
here and even more
if you look at people that are just
between design and development that are
not a designer not yet a developer
but they can help bridge between
uh your designers and your design
developers and can translate because
they speak both languages
and i think only if we all
talk to each other communicate with each
other
we can build something great like if you
remember
masaccio was only able to
paint
the trinita after brunelleschi told him
how to do this
and
i just hope that we all can work
together like this communicate with each
other and build something that rises
above the noise and doesn't look
like all the same layout and website all
over again
and that's it thank you very much
[Applause]